[Music]
hey you guys and thanks for tuning in GG
live I am Katie Krauss and younger fans
rejoice the season 5 finale is tonight
Charles Michael Davis is here I have so
many questions for you but I know that
you guys must have questions too so make
sure that you send them in right now I'm
gonna get them right here on this iPad I
kind of want to jump right in with a
clip okay and I want your reaction to it
let's roll it
it's mentioned a capital letters party
that Joe Biden is throwing in DC
tomorrow Cassie how could you not inform
me of this actually it's the first I'm
hearing about it myself why so out of
the loop
I thought you talked to your authors
Kelsey we need someone there did
something happen between you and your
writer I thought you two had quite the
tight relationship I'm happy to go to DC
it's my book I'll be there I'm sure it's
a private party that he felt didn't need
mentioning still it's all very strange
Peters well private or not I'm getting a
press release out about this immediately
Vaden Kelsey that relationship is one of
my favorites to watch explain what's
going on in that clip triangle and
Kelsey made the mistake of getting
involved with yeah but seems like Zayn
has developed real feelings for Kelsey
yeah yeah is that more of a case of oh
he wants what he shouldn't have or is it
a case of you know he really does like
this girl I think he finally met a girl
that he really likes it but before her
it was all about career and so now
here's that balance and so now he's kind
of got to face that and you know I think
you'll see there's a surprise in
tonight's episode that will I think help
push that forward with Zayn and Kelsey
yeah yeah okay yeah what do you make of
that relationship do you think it's a
good idea the relationship is a good
idea
I think it's me as co-workers as
co-workers yeah they want the best for
each other they push each other you know
they they kind of sharpen each other and
by doing that it's good for the authors
that they represent especially in a
dying sort of a seemingly dying field
right
you know publication sure yeah what
about romance wise yeah you know
somebody asked a question before like
where do you see Zanon Kelsey yeah we
just said we looked at each other and
the interview was like that they could
just be friends and
because you don't think they'll be
married I was like that thought never
crossed my mind that these two would be
that compatible for marriage right
romantically there's a nice fire there
with a competitiveness but I think when
they challenge each other it seems like
yeah people like to watch how would you
describe tonight's finale surprising a
lot of surprises okay any other romance
twists that we're gonna see maybe Liza
and Charles oh yeah but nothing I can
give away come on but yeah there's
definitely some developments with Liza
and Charles I think just as shocking as
the opener was for season five yeah yeah
the finale of be just as shocking how
our fans gonna feel at the end don't we
see all those surprises like they can't
wait to watch season six
I think after every episode and you're a
fan of the show I love the show can you
tell yeah it's fun fact he actually
brought me a shirt with all the
characters the female characters things
on it they're great but after every show
he ends up feeling good you know most
people that I've talked to you know it's
one of the shows that afterwards you
always just feel a little bit better
yeah
and you can't wait for next week yeah
and how long are we gonna have to wait
for season six
oh don't hold your breath too long you
might know and not not that long we
usually start shooting like February
March of each year yeah and then come
back and air by June I believe so next
summer we'll have it yeah what do you
want to see Darren star confirm that
you're gonna be back for season six
what do you want to see Zane
accomplished well I'd like to see him
one catch a break he hasn't really
caught a break with any of his authors
right this game it's been hard for him
yeah yeah so I'd like to see him kind of
you know find his own lane so he can
really move forward with his career yeah
with life and and see what develops with
yeah yeah it's so fun to see Hilary Duff
pregnant mm-hmm how excited are you
oh I remember when she when she told me
yeah you know we were all sitting
together and she's like guys you know we
shot
promo and we were in bumper cars and
when I was saying don't bump me in the
cars for a specific reason she goes at
the time she's like I'm three months
pregnant
was everyone shocked yeah yeah yeah yeah
we were all kind of this whole ting you
know piecing it together and just so
happy for what was your favorite way
that she had to hide the bump well she
um you know she was only three months so
you know she wasn't like you know
showing too much is she you know she
looks great and everything yeah
she's got all these beautiful other
quality they're so distracting yeah
that's it we have a question from
Danielle over on YouTube is Charles ever
going to be a guest on legacies as it
returns what we were talking about this
legacies is of course the spin-off of
the originals
yeah character did survive in the finale
yeah yeah and he did promise to always
be there if ever she needs so if hope
ever gets into a bind and yeah I think
Marcel will be there okay what did you
make of the finale people were a little
bit divided did you feel that yeah yeah
yeah I I was a little divided about it
you know all good things have to come to
an end so I thought I thought was a very
emotional episode though for sure I
thought they did the writers did a great
job did you steal anything from set I
did why'd you take it I took some I took
the boot what didn't I take I took boots
I took jacket Daniel Gillies told us the
same thing he took all of his suits he's
like they're made for me who else is
gonna wear that that's true I even took
one of Daniels jackets
does he know yeah yeah in front of him
okay he's like that's a good jacket go
it's yours you should know are you still
in touch with the cast at all yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's all Daniel Campbell
when I was in New York I saw Daniel
Gillies as well we did a little
convention in Atlanta okay what do you
make of the fandom I mean there's two
completely different fandoms between the
originals and then younger right
you know there there is and there's a
crossover you know even had a convention
for the originals I got a lot of people
that said they're huge fans of younger
and now I'll get approached by people on
the street where before I used to just
assume that they were originals fans
yeah and they'll go I love the show I
can't wait there's only two more
episodes or they'll say I love the show
and I'll go you know I'm like which one
Yeah right now but what I notice is that
they it leaves a good feeling for all of
them so much that they feel that they
you know want to come up and say how
much they they really enjoy the show
yeah and that's something special where
you don't get it with you know every
show totally yeah going back to
Hillary's pregnancy really fast was
there ever a conversation about writing
it into the show or is it Devereaux's
well you said there's a love triangle
yeah not that I know I wasn't a part of
any and I wasn't privy to any of that or
never heard anything about making that a
part of the show no okay
have you talked to Darren at all about
season six like do you know where things
are going um I don't know I know you
know they got to get started on that
storyline you know because they got a
you know get everything in all the ducks
in order and it's one of the things that
I talked to him about last year's
storyline how do they figure out they
have some ideas in LA and they're
sitting in a writers in LA then current
events happen between that time sure and
then they go back to New York so they
they read tool everything oh wow those
things go along well it was interesting
that they did the whole Reese
Witherspoon yeah sort of storyline has
Reese reached out to you guys at all is
she aware I don't know we asked about
that because we thought you know could
you get in trouble with that and you go
oh it's Darren star you know he's he's
probably fine with that he's not only
he's finally but I'm sure he finds his
ways like he sees thorough about
everything and we wouldn't do anything
to get into trouble
you know I'm waiting for that Reese
cameo me too
yeah Reese if you're watching you love
to see you on younger please slide in
our DMS priest-like CT she could very
well be watching I don't know yeah what
kind of series or books do you want to
see Zane take on and see
six I mean we had the whole like sort of
Game of Thrones and series we have the
political book
I won't seem to nonfiction exactly yes
together yeah we can write the show for
ya okay yeah I will just called speaking
of romance we were scrolling through
your Instagram your girlfriend is
stunning oh thank you how long is this
serious yeah I mean when I was in New
York you know one of the great things
about blessing and shooting the show
there was I met her yeah and she's
actually I'm out here in LA okay and so
yeah we're together together yeah how
many how long has it been it's been a
few months okay yeah what is it about
the relationship that makes it work do
you think I think it's that she's you
know she's just pretty ground and
especially when it comes to relationship
I think the current culture today it's
like you know it is a hook-up culture
and I think that makes you lose sight of
really wanting to fall in love and have
somebody you know and that was one thing
that I noticed when I first met her and
so it made it very easy to really just
like snatch her up and commit to him
you're my girlfriend yeah make a
beautiful couple thank you a couple more
questions from you guys and we're gonna
wrap up soon so if you have any send
them in right now Cara over on YouTube
says how do you feel plain of vampire in
originals to the character in this
meaning younger I think um well when I
first got on the originals I pitched
this idea that my character gets to wear
suits and they go well clearly you
haven't been watching the show because
Daniel Gillies his character always
wears suit yeah so then when I got over
to younger and I was in nothing but
suits and being in New York you know
they put me in like adultery and
Gabbana's sued or that show is amazing
yeah yeah it's sick so that was one of
the differences was
you know just being able to wear suit
and and and embody that character yeah
the character carried himself and much
different and a different kind of
swagger yeah okay and I didn't bite
people that's the only other difference
thank you for that Tonya says what actor
do you most want to work with Denzel
Washington yeah I only seen him in
passing I froze what you gotta figure
that out for next time yeah yeah but
then another actor he's doing very well
right now is actually in a film with
Denzel Washington Pedro Pascal yeah yeah
we'd actually both auditioned for the
role of Marcel
oh no way yeah you were to say you
auditioned for Game of Thrones no no no
no he's doing all right
yeah but he's such a tremendous actor
and and such a cool dude I'd love to
work with him totally one of my favorite
questions to ask people do you remember
the first audition that you went out for
um I do I do because I had actually the
first like television audition because I
had actually booked it what yeah guys
come on two months in it what was it
it's a little co-star role on that So
Raven still and I'm not even
recognizable I have this I have this
hair that's out to here like a little
Bruno Mars kind of hearing yeah yeah
it's it's real funny do you still talk
to Raven no no okay
no I haven't seen haven't had crossed
paths with here yeah the show's still
doing well yeah yeah and then what about
a role that you went out for that you
didn't get that you were like oh man
there was there wasn't any roles that I
was like oh man because usually when I
see the person that they cast yeah I'm
like now they're they're pretty perfect
for it yeah but there's some that I
would have been excited to kind of be a
part of like I was actually founded the
divergent series so good yeah yeah yeah
there's a part that I would yeah it
wasn't it wasn't
that big of a part at the time but it
would've been fun to be a part of it
yeah I read those books hmm yeah yes
happy reading I like reading you guys um
anyways before we wrap up let us let
fans know why they should tune in to the
finale tonight because you're gonna be
disappointed because everyone's gonna be
talking about it the next day so if you
don't watch it tonight alive you're
gonna be you're gonna get a lot of
spoils spoilers spoilers really yeah so
watch it tonight yes I want to be Landin
season 5 premiere of younger thank you
so much for being here and talking and
for being so open with us you guys make
sure to tune in to the season 5 finale
of younger tonight on TV land and make
sure that you keep up with Charles
Michael Davis on all things social media
he's on Instagram he's on Twitter and if
anybody's about Twitter for money it's
not me it's not really you or Facebook
don't respond to those people I this is
not my jam I read a fake Twitter today
send the record straight oh well thank
you guys so much and we'll see you next
time
[Music]